so I've been asked periodically for a
couple decades whether I think
artificial intelligence is possible and
I taught the artificial intelligence
course at Columbia University I've
always been fascinated by the concept of
intelligence it's a subjective word I've
always been very skeptical and I am I'm
only now newly a believer now this is
subjective this is this is sort of an
aesthetic thing but my opinion is that
IBM's Watson computer that's able to
answer questions in my subjective view
that qualifies as intelligence I spent
six years in graduate school working on
two things one is machine learning and
that's the core to prediction learning
from data how to predict that's also
known as predictive modeling and the
other is natural language processing or
computational linguistics working with
human language because that really ties
in to the way we think of what we're
capable of doing and does turn out to be
extremely hard for computers to do now
playing the TV quiz show Jeopardy means
you're answering answering questions
quiz quiz show questions the questions
in that game show are really complex
grammatically and it turns out that in
order to answer them Watson looks at
huge amounts of text for example a
snapshot of all the english-speaking
Wikipedia articles and it has to process
text not only to look at the question
that's trying to answer but to retrieve
the retrieve the answers themselves now
at the court of this turns out it's
using predictive modeling now it's not
predicting the future but it's
predicting the answer to the question
you know it's the same in that it's
inferring an unknown even though someone
else may already know the answer so
there's no sort of future thing but will
this turn out to be the answer to the
question the core technology is the same
in both cases learning from examples in
the case of Watson playing the TV show
jeopardy it takes hundreds of thousands
of previous jeopardy questions from the
TV show having gone on for decades and
learns from them and what's learning to
do is predict is
candidate answer to this question likely
to be the correct answer so it's going
to come up with a whole bunch of
candidate answers hundreds of candidate
answers for the one question at hand at
any given point in time and the amongst
all these candidate answers it's going
to score each one how likely is it to be
the right answer and of course the one
that gets the highest score as the
highest vote of confidence that's
ultimately the one answer it's going to
give it's correct I believe about 90 or
92 percent of the time of the time that
it actually buzzes in to intentionally
answer the question you can go on
YouTube and you can watch the the
episode where they aired the you know
the competition between the IBM's
computer Watson and the all-time to
human champions of Jeopardy and it just
rattled off one answer after another and
just doesn't matter how many years
you've been looking at in fact maybe the
more years you've studied the ability or
inability of computers to work with
human language the more impressive it is
is just rattling one answer after
another I never thought that in my
lifetime I would have cause to
experience that the way I did which was
wow that's anthropomorphic this computer
seems like a person in that very
specific skillset that's incredible I'm
gonna call that intelligent
you